un patient à Berlin en 2009 un à Londres
en 2019 et un troisième à Düsseldorf en
février ces dernières années plusieurs
cas de rémission du VIH ont été
constatés alors cela veut-il dire que
l'on pourra bientôt guérir du virus
le virus du sida a été identifié pour la
première fois en 1983 par l'Institut
Pasteur depuis le début de l'épidémie 84
millions de personnes ont été infectées
par le VIH et plus de 40 millions de
personnes sont décédées des suites des
maladies liées au sida alors le VIH et
c'est le virus et le sida c'est la
maladie c'est exactement comme le sarce
of 2 qui est le virus le coronavirus
responsable c'est le virus responsable
de covid la maladie donc c'est
exactement la même chose donc souvent on
parle de virus du sida le sida c'est la
maladie c'est la maladie finale stade
finale de l'infection par le VIH le VIH
s'attaque au système au système
immunitaire il rentre dans les
lymphocytes et progressivement il induit
la dégradation du système immunitaire au
stade sida bien il y a des infections il
y a des atteintes pulmonaires
progressives et le sida conduit à la
mort fin 2021 l'Organisation Mondiale de
la Santé estimait à 38,4 millions le
nombre de personnes vivant avec le VIH
dans le monde en France environ 174 000
personnes sont séropositives on a la
certitude que si on fait un diagnostic
précoce de son infection on peut
recevoir des traitements très tôt et
vivre je dirais quasiment normalement
avec le VIH à condition de prendre des
traitements à vie puisqu'on va le voir
le virus reste dans l'organisme à vie on
ne sait pas le déloger mais par contre
on sait le bloquer on peut désormais
vivre avec le virus mais il n'existe
toujours pas de moyens d'en guérir
pourtant plusieurs cas de rémission ont
été recensés depuis les années 2000 ce
sont des cas assez particuliers en fait
ce sont trois personnes qui en raison
d'un cancer du sang ont reçu une greffe
de moelle qui a un traitement très lourd
parce que ça implique d'abord
d'éradiquer tout le système immunitaire
de la personne pour ensuite lui faire
une greffe et ensuite la mettre sous aux
immunosuppresseur à vie ce qui ce qui
implique des effets indésirables assez
conséquent et donc ça a permis
d'éradiquer les cellules dans leur
organisme ou persistaient le virus du
VIH que ça reste un traitement
extrêmement lourd qu'on ne peut proposer
que dans des cas très particuliers de
personnes qui n'ont pas d'autres option
thérapeutiques pour soigner leur cancer
du sein et en fait finalement la
guérison de VIH n'est qu'un effet de
bord très positif mais c'était pas le
but principal recherché dans chaque cas
de rémission des conditions bien
particulières sont réunies le patient
porteur de VIH est atteint d'un cancer
du sein
cancer pour lequel il bénéficie d'une
greffe de moelle osseuse et enfin son
donneur porte la mutation CCR5 Delta 32
qui empêche le virus d'entrer dans les
cellules mais concrètement à quelle
fréquence ces conditions sont-elles
réunies alors pour vous donner une idée
dans la population européenne cette
mutation qui rend résistant au VIH elle
est présent dans environ 1% des
personnes donc il faut que cette
personne soit donneuse et le taux de
compatibilité quand c'est quelqu'un qui
n'est pas de votre famille c'est un sur
un million à peu près donc je vous
laisse faire les calculs la probabilité
de trouver un donneur compatible qui a
cette mutation et pour qui la greffe va
fonctionner elle est très faible les cas
de rémission restent donc pour leur
rarissime et surtout n'ont pas permis de
trouver une solution réplicable à grande
échelle alors quelles autres pistes
s'offrent aujourd'hui aux chercheurs pas
beaucoup de pistes maintenant pour pour
la recherche malheureusement je peux pas
donner une date de
quand on pense qu'on arrivera à une cure
ou en tout cas un traitement ou acquérir
du VIH quand on a découvert le virus en
1983 les chercheurs les chercheuses de
l'époque étaient convaincus de trouver
le moyen de d'éradiquer le virus dans
les mois les années à venir et
finalement on fête aujourd'hui les 40
ans de la découverte de ce virus et on a
toujours pas trouvé le moyen il y a
toujours des vaccins à l'étude des
vaccins qui sont en phase 1 d'ailleurs à
l'heure actuelle on est toujours en
train d'essayer de trouver parce qu'on
peut avoir à la fois un vaccin
protecteur mais aussi à la fois un
vaccin qui pourrait aider à stabiliser à
retirer le VIH on a aussi beaucoup
d'espoir dans des nouveaux traitements
des nouveaux traitements de longue durée
puisque pour le moment on est sur une
prise par jour ce qui est quand même
bien mieux que les nombreux médicaments
qu'il y avait à prendre avant et là on
est en train d'arriver sur des
traitements injectables à une injection
par mois même une injection tous les
deux mois et on attend avec impatience
des traitements avec une injection tous
les six mois qui permettrait aux
personnes vivant avec le village de
vivre avec une qualité de vie encore
meilleure qui est le vivent à l'heure
actuelle si la recherche a fait
d'immenses progrès depuis la découverte
du virus il y a 40 ans il est encore
impossible de guérir du VIH dans la
majorité des cas en 2021 650 000
personnes sont mortes du sida cela
représente environ un mort par minute
[Musique]
[Rires]